[Musik]
mailbox speichern
der nächste ja guten tag gonzales hier
ja endlich wissen sie wie oft ich heute
schon angerufen habe entschuldigung
nicht mehr beschäftigt das hoffe ich
ich möchte mich beschweren ja das haben
sie in der menschen geschrieben ich bin
extrem unzufrieden die app funktioniert
nicht die website ist viel zu
unübersichtlich wie soll man sich denn
da noch orientieren ich verstehe ihr
problem wir können die website nach
ihren wünschen ändern
sie ändern gar nichts mehr unsere
zusammenarbeit beendet aber hat freut
sich tablets die sie uns empfohlen haben
auch mit die sind so langsam ich möchte
sie umtauschen die rechnung habe ich
noch das ist ihr gutes recht was soll
das heißen ich bekomme mein geld doch
zurück oder ich habe doch eine
rückgabegarantie das ist leider nicht
möglich ist häufig nicht möglich
das werden wir ja sehen
der nächste